avec nous ce soir pierre olivier pineau
qui titulaire de la chaire de gestion du
secteur de l'énergie de hec montréal et
éric tétreault qui président de
l'association de l'énergie du québec
messieurs bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
fusion est ce que l'abandon monsieur
titre ou d'abord tient est-ce que
l'abandon de cayston est un moment
charnière cette semaine un point
marquant pour l'industrie canadienne du
pétrole et du gaz naturel
je ne crois pas je pense que keystone xl
c'est d'abord été un symbole ça a été le
théâtre de la lutte entre les gens qui
qui s'opposent au développement de
l'industrie pétrolière et l'industrie
elle-même mais dans les faits qui se
tourne excellent c'était une demande
c'était pour satisfaire une demande aux
états unis demande accrue et avec les
deux projets de pipelines en cours au
canada actuellement le projet de trans
manten avec 535 mais le baril de plus
par jour et la ligne trop d'un bridge et
à 390 me je crois de mémoire de risques
supplémentaires par jour
il se pourrait très bien que
l'infrastructure actuelle est prévu
répondent amplement aux besoins de
l'industrie pétrolière canadienne à
fournir à la demande
alors ok très bien je comprends bien
donc c'est une mauvaise nouvelle sans
doute pour l'industrie pétrolière mais
c'est pas la fin du monde dites vous
chez pinault vous en pensez quoi mais
c'était quelque chose qu'on avait
compris en fait donc c'est l'abandon
officiel par tc énergie le promoteur de
kiston mai mais le gouvernement
américain avait déjà annoncé qu'il
retirait son permis présidentielle donc
c'est pas une nouvelle et l'industrie du
pétrole et en transformation ces années
ci est alors je pense pas que cet
événement soit une rupture marquée par
rapport à l'ensemble des turbulences et
l'avait tendance est ce que ça vaut la
peine pierre olivier pineau de continuer
de soutenir le pétrole de développer le
pétrole les installations pétrolières
les projets d'oléoducs
mais c'est sûr que la ligue le contexte
n'a pas vraiment changé depuis le début
il faut il ne faudrait pas soutenir ce
secteur-là travers des fonds publics
les subventions ça fait longtemps que
c'est documenté à l'échelle
internationale qu'il faut essayer
d'arrêter les subventions à l'industrie
du pétrole c'est très compliqué parce
que ça prend diverses formes qui sont
des battable ci à savoir si c'est une
subvention ou non mais globalement au
canada c'est vraiment une industrie qui
est financé par des investisseurs privés
donc c'est ce n'est pas le gouvernement
qui soutient l'industrie et par contre
le message clair qu'il faut envoyer
l'industrie c'est qu'il y à une
transition qui se prépare et je pense
que l'industrie la de plus en plus
intégré cette transition l'a alors
l'industrie se transforme se diversifie
et je crois qu'elle va accompagner la
transition énergétique qui est à venir
monsieur tu es trop là dessus est ce que
il faut soutenir encore est-ce qu'il
faut subventionner encore et est ce que
le soutien dans le fond il va aux
énergies renouvelables il devrait aller
directement aux énergies renouvelables
d'abord le soutien gouvernemental va
beaucoup plus à l'énergie renouvelable
qu'à l'industrie pétrolière actuellement
monsieur pinault l'a10 est largement
financée par des intérêts privés alors
et le gouvernement soutient le secteur
parce que c'est 10% entre 5 et 10% du
pib selon les calculs que vous faites et
le secteur est soutenu comme tous les
grands secteurs industriels au canada il
n'y a pas de subvention n'y a pas de
gouvernement canadien qui fait un chèque
avec juste les pétrolières cela étant
dit vous avez mis le doigt sur quelque
chose de très intéressant
l'industrie effectivement se transforme
et vaut faire partie de cette vaste
transition énergétique là et on a vu
cette semaine par exemple les cinq plus
grands producteurs canadiens s'allier
ensemble pour pour promettre que leur
propre industrie c'est à dire l'état
dire les les émissions produites
n'est ce pas pendant la production du
pétrole et des hydrocarbures et non pas
les émissions dues aux transports
c'est c'est autre chose donc elles ont
elles ont promis donc de faire comme
tout le monde c'est à dire d'y aller
avec 9 025 en mai ce qui est passé de
plus inaperçu c'était c'est cet
investissement d'1 3 milliard de air
products
des états unis à edmonton pour produire
de l'hydrogène par exemple alors quand
monsieur pinault dit ya beaucoup de
solutions qui vont venir de l'industrie
y en aura énormément on en fabrique ici
chez nous chez vallée rouge c'est son
corps de l'hydrogène aussi alors
l'industrie envoie le message très clair
qu'elle vaut faire partie de cette
tradition là et donc elle fait partie de
la solution l'industrie pétrolière mais
olivier pineau fait partie de la
solution
on peut peut-être pas aller jusque là
mais c'est certain que la transition
énergétique devra se faire avec la
collaboration et non pas dans
l'affrontement alors il faut prendre
acte de nos de notre consommation et
surtout agir essentiellement pourra
réussir à ne plus utiliser de produits
pétroliers comme on utilise aujourd'hui
l'industrie elle regarde beaucoup les
tendances de consommation qui sont
encore malgré la covit qui sont encore à
la reprise delà de la faute de la
consommation de pétrole
on anticipe le d'ici 2022 on va
retrouver le niveau de consommation
mondiale et même au canada antérieure à
la halle à coxyde
donc il faut il faut nous changer comme
consommateur avec l'accompagnement des
gouvernements mais il est certain que
l'industrie devra utiliser son savoir
faire pour développer des nouveaux
produits des nouveaux services qui vont
aider la transition énergétique
est ce que ça vaut la peine que jason
kenney que l'alberta que son
gouvernement qui a quand même investi 1
milliard 300 millions qui perd 1
milliard 300 millions dans la verdure
qui stone excellent aille de l'avant
avec une plainte est une démarche qu'ils
se battent en justice en vertu de
l'alena pour obtenir compensation auprès
d'administrations maiden éric tétreault
l'élu du sondage en alberta ça va pas
très bien pour monsieur qu'est né alors
oui ils ont soutenu le projet qui se
tourne à hauteur de 1,3 milliard
la question c'est s'il ne l'avait pas
fait et si qui se tourne avait été
abandonnée quelle aurait été la réaction
moi je pense que ça aurait été pire
lhérisson quand le gouvernement il
raison de se battre
ben je pense qu'il devra se battre
jusqu'au bout c'est une
il n'y a pas d'autres avenues politique
pour monsieur k n'est actuellement que
de se battre jusqu'au bout pour qu'ils
se tournent excellent étant donné départ
sur quoi le gouvernement le canadien ne
le fait pas ce qui a aidé bien sûr la
décision du président wade donne alors
moi je pense que reçu monsieur koné n'a
pas n'a pas le choix il devra aller
jusqu'au bout de serre qu est-ce que
l'abandon de kystes homme puis les
problèmes avec la canalisation qui passe
au michigan qui pourrait être bloqué par
le michigan
est ce que ça peut relancer un autre
projet un vieux projet qui est qui qui
qui devait avoir lieu au canada qui
était vraiment très précieux pour
l'industrie et qui a été abandonnée
énergie est je me suis trop d'opposition
et les gouvernements sont quand même
très engagé qu'envoie la lutte contre le
changement climatique d'ici 2030
on va avoir une taxe sur le carbone à
hauteur de 170 dollars par le
gouvernement fédéral 30 et 40 cents le
litre
la technologie des véhicules électriques
aura nettement évolué et donc les
options seront largement disponibles
donc le march is et or a radicalement
changé dans le long terme et plus
d'investisseurs de france rock le sien
le rejet non il fait d'accord avec
monsieur pinault il y avait une partie
de la réponse dans votre question me
suffit clients quels risques politiques
versus l'utilité d'avoir une énergie est
ce parce que monsieur pinault a bien
répondu sur la volonté politique d'aller
de l'avant par contre mes témoins
commentaire c'est facile pour monsieur
byden de mettre une croix sur kiston
excellent 1 sachant que le partenaire au
nord ne réagira pas c'est une autre
paire de manches d'aller s'opposer à
nord stream 2 qui permettrait au gaz
naturel russe d'aller en allemagne en
autriche et aux pays bas
je sais pas si mal fait roger c'est
madame merkel n'est pas trop loin
il pourra certainement en parler mais il
est beaucoup plus discret là dessus
alors je reviens sur qui se tendaient
qsssl c'est facile pour les
gouvernements d'avoir des cibles
politiques kif qui les fait bien
paraître c'est autre chose que d'agir
sur le marché généralement le marché va
dicter les politiques énergétiques et
dont le contraire et si la 160 et si la
taxe carbone
le clean fuel stands
supino en parlait à 170 la tonne vaut
comme les économistes le prédisent donné
lieu à une hausse des prix et des
denrées partout et si ça devait
provoquer une récession
on aura un autre paire de manches et à
gérer au gouvernement fédéral
tous les gouvernements vont chercher à
réduire les émissions j'en connais aucun
qui va vouloir aller en élection avec
une récession
non c'est pas très agréable généralement
pierre olivier pineau merci éric
tétreault également c'était très
intéressant
merci monsieur fillion un prochain
trouve pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit